es ist soweit schon sehr bald können wir
in städten mit flug taxen von a nach b
fliegen und sehr bald heißt nicht etwa
in ein paar jahren sondern noch dieses
jahr wo und wann diese menschen drohen
zuerst eingesetzt werden jetzt in
kriegszeiten sind fiction herzlich
willkommen
die entwicklung schreitet mit
hochgeschwindigkeit voran immer mehr und
immer besser drohnen fliegen durch die
lüfte in deutschland werden 2020 eine
millionen drohnen unterwegs sein so
schätzt die deutsche flugsicherung aber
es werden noch keine flug taxen sein
oder mindestens nicht so viele es wird
überall daran gearbeitet geforscht und
entwickelt es hat ein richtiger pad lauf
um diese menschen drohen begonnen und
die chinesen scheinen die nase vorn zu
haben wahrscheinlich werden sie die
ersten sein die den regulären betrieb
aufnehmen aber auch hier in deutschland
stehen die zeichen auf drohnen das
deutsche startup evolution 2018 flug
taxen in deutschland einsetzen doch
zunächst in singapur den volo copter so
heißt diese drohne testen die riesige
stadt ächzt unter dem verkehr und
singapurs verkehrsminister pankin gehen
will drohnen menschen drohnen einsetzen
um den verkehr in der metropole in den
griff zu bekommen drohnen haben dabei
große vorteile sie verbrauchen deutlich
weniger energie als ein pkw sind viel
schneller am ziel benutzen kürzere
routen und verbrauchen dadurch noch mal
weniger energie und sie verstopfen nicht
die straßen bei uns gibt noch zahlreiche
ungeklärte fragen gibt es hier in
deutschland für solche flug taxen
keinerlei rechtlichen rahmen im
gegenteil städte sind grundsätzlich
erstmals flugverbotszonen in die nur mit
genehmigung eingeflogen werden darf die
software die muss so entwickelt werden
dass es keine zusammenstöße gibt es muss
gewährleistet werden dass die drohnen
landen bevor die batterien leer sind und
so weiter und so fort in dubai ist man
zuversichtlich all diese probleme
achtung jetzt kommt bis zum sommer aus
dem weg zum hier sollen dann die ersten
autonomen drohenden taxen fliegen der
chinesische hersteller hat eine drohne
konstruiert die per app bestellt wird
und den fluggast dann zu dem gewünschten
ort transportiert ohne dass der gast
irgendetwas
der flug wird dabei aus einer zentrale
beobachtet und im notfall auch
korrigiert das 184 hiv kann bis zu 30
minuten in der luft bleiben fliegt 160
km/h spitze und hat eine reichweite von
40 bis 50 kilometern die zukunft kommt
eben manchmal schneller als man denkt
wir halten euch natürlich hier über das
thema auf dem laufen wenn er dazu nichts
verpassen wollt dann sollten wir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht
mehr an auf die glocke zu geben und wer
bisher liegt nur noch nicht abonniert
hat der hat das verpasst unsere besser
playlist draufklicken und ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran